there's a pastor in Baltimore
his name is Michael Phillips he is the
pastor of kingdom Life Church and he
often talks about how problems show up
in our lives so arrogantly with so much
confidence as if there's just nothing we
can do about him and the murder rate in
Baltimore have been doing that year
after year it just kept showing up as
this big thing that there was nothing
any of us could do anything about but
the thing about Baltimore is that it has
never been the one to just be defeated
so the story about the Baltimore
ceasefire is that Baltimore look the
murder rate in the eye and said what
you're not going to do is snatch our
greatness so two years ago I met a 300
men March meeting at the time I was a
leader in that movement and this guy
named ogoun he's like a godfather of
hip-hop in Baltimore he came over to me
and he said yo I had this idea about
calling the ceasefire in Baltimore and I
feel like you are somebody I should talk
to about that and I was like I'm
absolutely somebody you should talk to
about that because that's not wish today
and so we play phone tag and meeting tag
and two years went by and we never
really sat down and talked about it so
now we're in May of 2017 my son Paul
he's 19 years old he's driving me home
from work one day and he says my did you
know that the murder rate in Baltimore
is higher than it's ever been and I said
what you mean is higher than it's ever
been how is that possible like I mean
what about these people who say they
have connections to the streets why
won't they use those connections and
call a ceasefire or something in Orono
and I went from my own feelings of
helplessness about what other people
weren't doing the next morning I woke up
and I realized that what I was really
angry about wasn't about what other
people weren't doing it was that I had
heard this message years ago and I
hadn't moved on it so it was it was
about what I was supposed to be doing so
I got up and I'm going okay and we could
just have three days where everybody in
the city was committing nobody is going
to kill anybody and we're going to
celebrate life instead when can we do
that so it's may I look
my calendar I'm like right I got some
free time the first weekend in August
we're good we'll do it August 4th
through August 6 right so I'm all
excited I start driving the work and the
more I Drive the scatter I get right and
so I start going never mind I won't say
this thing out loud nobody will ever
know I was thinking that if I don't say
it but it wouldn't let me go because God
loves to show up as us and because I
look broken and I'm always called to
standing my wholeness
there was a call on my life to say this
thing out loud and because my city looks
broken
and it's always yearning to show up in
its wholeness that will Hut's that
morning calling all through my chest
that people around the city wanted to do
something great together and people who
had already been killed in my city were
calling to me up through my gut in my
chest as a nut in my throat yo e you
cannot just let us be dead in vain when
you know how to say this thing out loud
and I responded to them with my fear but
somebody might get killed anyway that
weekend and that was the moment where I
had to accept that maybe while we're out
spreading this message hey nobody's
going to kill anybody we're going to
celebrate life maybe somebody will be
plotting to take a life right then and
there but now they would have a rumbling
in their spirits and so I knew it was
time for my city to have a collective
rumbling in our spirits so I got on the
phone got around the old going and I
said yo you said you wanted to do a
ceasefire what is it I'm ready so he
said you know when I hear about like the
Israelis and Palestinians at whoa I'm
like oh that's too bad they should stop
that but when I hear the word ceasefire
that makes me pause and stop and really
research what's going on and he wanted
Baltimore to get that same kind of
attention from the outside but
introspection from the inside about what
was going on with us and we've talked
about how it couldn't belong to one
person not one person or one
organization should call a ceasefire the
whole city had to own it and do it
together so we had our first meeting in
May about 12 or 15 people show up
and this is where it gives name the
Baltimore ceasefire because you know
what that means when you hear the word
ceasefire just don't kill nobody and
this is where the Baltimore Peace
challenge was born because it's not just
about not being violent it is about
being purposefully peaceful what is
going on and your thoughts what kind of
petty things are you not saying out of
your mouth how are you responding in
your behaviors to conflict I grabbed up
five people who I trusted and the six of
us became the organizing squad so let's
give them props real quick on the count
of three I want you to yell squad one
two three
squad and it's Charlotte's birthday
happy birthday Charlotte's right and so
we put out a press release and the media
told us this is not really a story yet
we will get with you in August segments
to see how the ceasefire went so we went
a word all right then and Baltimore got
to work and not only did people send
money to the PayPal account so we could
buy flyers and posters people came and
got the flowers and posters and they put
them all around the city and people were
having conversations with each other
what kind of resources do you need what
are you going through what has happened
to you because we understand the root
causes of violence in this country
people who said it wouldn't work still
into their sentence with but please keep
trying somebody needs to do something
anyway teenagers who would tell us about
the stuff they were doing in the streets
all day ask but can I have a poster to
put it on my world at night so I can see
it on my way to be geist is what Carla's
saying I can tell you where violence is
not going to come from because we're
committing to the peace challenge and
they kept their word when people said oh
it's not gonna work because somebody's
gonna kill over Wessel somebody's gonna
kill all over east we said that doesn't
matter
it's about self-determination yo you
telling me you can't keep this three or
six block radius safe and they would say
oh don't get it twisted is gonna stay
safe around here and they kept their
promise
[Applause]
for a song and I know it looks like I'm
holding up five fingers but I have four
fingers so this is four for me four
songs got made about the Baltimore
ceasefire and the one that most
exemplifies that we're a bunch of
artists came together and made a song
that one is currently nominated for a
Grammy out here right and so now what
was happening was from the most
beautiful corners of crack houses to the
grimy is corners of politicians offices
everybody was talking about this thing
Baltimore was doing together right and
then the weekend came events all over
the city people yell a happy ceasefire a
day over 200 people got their records
expunged and got jobs and people went
into drug recovery programs because of
what was happening in our city that
weekend people were going but the air
feels different in Baltimore nobody's
mother got that phone call last night I
didn't hear any gunshots and on Saturday
trade went to go get a job and was
excited about it at 24 hours of no
killing we were singing Kendrick Lamar
we're gonna be all right we're gonna be
all right and then at 4:59 on saturday
we get a message that somebody was
killed we didn't know his name but it
turned out to be Trey so we rushed over
to sergeant Street and we held hands in
a circle and we looked at the pavement
and we said this is sacred ground
because we make it so because everywhere
in our city where people lose their
lives to violence needs to be sacred
ground and it wasn't just about
upholding Trey in his transition and
sending love to his family it was about
us pausing to really think about what
must it feel like 20 minutes after you
kill somebody can't we pour love into
that cuz until we do we will not heal
this epidemic later on in the day we get
another call Dante is murdered so by the
end of this day we were shook
in real life we were shook because we
had opened up our hearts together and
changed the atmosphere of the city and
now our hearts were broken together and
we had to be honest about the fact that
last weekend when we lost six people to
violence
it didn't feel the way it felt this
weekend when we lost these two because
now we were paying attention now we were
all hoping together that nobody got
killed and so we had to make a vow with
ourselves not to be numb anymore when we
lose people in our city these two lives
were going to remind us to vibrate
higher and to move forward so as we move
forward and to Baltimore ceasefire 365
because it's work that needs to be done
all year and there's another ceasefire
happening next weekend November 3rd
through 5th mark your calendar right and
we expect the same thing it was news
media from all around the world
Australia in Norway in China everybody
wanted to come get this work from
Baltimore and y'all can come get it
right so as we push fuller we don't need
to keep asking now what can we do we
have seen the power of collective
consciousness y'all were the ones who
misunderstood Baltimore your thought
Baltimore was just the wire when we lost
Freddie gray y'all saw the Baltimore
uprising and people around this world
mischaracterized it and misunderstood it
what you fail to realize is Baltimore is
the power to rise up and that is what we
continue to do and so as we move forward
we see you America with your systems of
violent oppression trying to beat us
into the ground and still we rise we
rise and stand where cities all over
this country just like us who are handed
through no fault of their own criminal
conditions in which to live and then
they get labeled savages for how they
live we stand with them we remind them
we are an example of what you can do
when you say no I don't have to accept
these conditions that you are trying to
hand me I get to decide what the
greatest vision
myself looks like and so the next time
you are faced with a dilemma with a
problem you can say let me be like
Baltimore let me look it in the face let
me tell it but what you're not going to
do its next my greatness
please believe it thank you
[Applause]